coach joins us here the Continental Tire
Coaches Corner now I know you went to
school here in Minnesota and I know
you've been listening to make love and
whine and moan about how cold it is on a
scale of one to ten how cold is it today
ten being the coldest today is about a 6
ok got a long ways to go by this weekend
you're gonna hope that it would be this
warm ok did you play football indoors we
were indoors
fortunately then you know the Big Ten
season ended around Thanksgiving so you
only had one or two really cold games
but Tom Moore was my quarterback coach
he was a bud grant school he didn't
believe in gloves no long sleeves if you
were a ball handler you had to be able
to feel the ball so we got used to
planning and cold-weather tell him the
story about when you were it was finals
week had a take home test at the
University of our semester up here you
know it's starting to get cold December
I have a take home final I did it in my
dorm all I had to do is go turn it in it
was like December 21st I walked outside
two steps and I said I don't know if
this is worth getting this grade I put
my head down and went about a block
further and I said forget this I know
that's cold that's cold but you played
in Pittsburgh with Chuck Noll how was
Chuck know we you know we everybody
talks about bud grant the Minnesota
Vikings coach and how he didn't want
heaters he didn't want gloves or
anything how was Chuck Noll on the side
osa Noah was fine do whatever you need
to do to play and get comfortable and we
had heaters on the sidelines he let us
wear the gloves and everything but I
remember the coldest game I ever played
in 78 AFC Championship game were playing
Houston is cold rain it hadn't snow but
just wet and cold and Rocky Bleier
they'd sent him in we're ahead and the
doctor said he needs to go in he's
getting hypothermia and he said don't
tell Chuck I have to go in because I'm
coming
tell him I'm hurt so here's rocky one of
the toughest guys who's ever played his
teeth were chattering it was just frozen
solid the doctor sent him in and he said
if coach is looking for me tell him I
did but when you play for these
legendary coaches you know we wondered
if Minnesota had an advantage when they
played outdoors the vibe absolutely but
could you do that today and use that as
a home-field advantage where I mean the
the Packers use it but why wouldn't the
Vikings take advantage of something like
that you know I think it's for the fans
so the stadium over here is beautiful
and and you don't want the fans to sit
out in that but it was definitely an
advantage when I was in college here and
I'd come out and watch some of those
playoff games
I mean blanket snowmobile suits and all
the equipment you could have on and
coach grant just told him hey this is
mental you got to disregard it and I
remember going out to practice one time
late in the year Sammy white was a
rookie from Grambling and Butz giving
him this whole story about it's all
mental and everything in between plays
Sammy's got his hands in his paws so
coach grant made him hold up the cards
the whole practice working with the
hands and by the next year he's totally
fine what was the philosophy or mindset
you had when you sent your guys into
media day media night but what was your
role as the coach before they went out
you know what I told them
have fun enjoy this enjoy the moment
we're not even gonna think put ball in
preparation until tomorrow so go out
there and have fun and know that there's
no such thing as bulletin board material
at the Super Bowl when you get here if
somebody needs a quote to make them play
hard against you it's not gonna matter
anyway so I didn't really worry about
that answer the questions enjoy it have
fun and then tomorrow we'll start the
serious football I know you spent some
time in Philadelphia we're talking to
Tony Dungy just that whole
chip-on-the-shoulder underdog how does
that play how do you travel with that to
Minneapolis they're gonna bring that no
question about it it's impacted them the
fact that they were underdogs at home
with the number one seed both games they
felt a disrespect now you really can't
use that and take it any further but
they're going to they've had that
underdog mentality the other thing they
have is just a lot of its new for them
you know I was talking to rotten and
he's in New England and it's kind of
ho-hum here we go again but these guys
it's exciting they're into it the city
and everything they're feeding off that
so it's I'm anxious to see how they're
gonna be but it was a very excited group
when I was there I look at
Philadelphia's being a better team than
New England you know both sides of the
ball like more balanced maybe less holes
than that but you have Brady Brady
versus Foles and it almost feels like
Brady is worth six points let's say if
carson wentz was the quarterback how
close do you think I mean is it I know
Foles has played well and I know you're
a big fold fan but if wench is playing
how are we looking at this game
differently I think we would be because
Bill Belichick as we know always says
I'm gonna take away what you do best and
I'm gonna make your weaknesses beat us
if your weakness can beat us then we'll
live with it so he's definitely is gonna
take away the quick passing game he's
gonna take away the run loaded up and
try to put the ball in Nick Foles his
hands well you couldn't really take that
strategy with carson wentz you can't say
I'm gonna sell out to everything and put
it in Wentz his hands so it's definitely
it would be an advantage if once played
but the key is gonna be fold if he plays
the way he played the last two games and
the moment isn't too big for him they're
gonna do well I know that the Eagles the
players think this is just Nick Foles
and they didn't do anything Doug
Peterson didn't tweak anything here but
but knowing Doug Peterson he tweaked
something with Nick Foles whether these
players understand that or not it's so
funny because I asked all those guys
that in the interviews knew our show
we'll have it on Sunday morning all the
offensive guys oh we haven't done one
thing different we just ran the same
plays over and over and then you talk to
Nick and you talk to coach Peterson well
here's what we did and here's you know
but what
happens you have maybe 300 plays in your
arsenal and so they ended up sorting
some things out and they're maybe
running 40 or 50 different things for
foals than they did from once now they
were all in and training camp but maybe
maybe they've they're running 80%
different yeah even though it was always
in the playbook what should I ask Tom
Brady tonight you should ask Tom Brady
how he stays so driven how you can play
at that high level and still motivated
to win six seven eight Super Bowls most
people after two or three with or four
hey I'm I'm in the elite of the whole
world but he is driven in folks I don't
know how you keep that over 20 years how
do you coach that I don't think you
coach it I think that's inside of
someone but who do you think is more
competitive Belichick or Brady I've seen
the Bill Belichick competitiveness of
close and personal so I have to say he
might be that he is probably a tie it's
probably close but I look at Brady and I
I don't know if this is the last hurrah
but you know that you just have to look
at the numbers and say you're 40
Belichick is 65 like he could coach 10
more years I guess right I think so but
we know Brady can't play 10 more years
but I don't know if this is the last
hurrah
I don't think Tom's looking at it that
way I think he's looking at hey we could
win two or three more I'm also
fascinated with this it let's say Brady
had missed that game against
Jacksonville because of the injury and
then it's Hoyer in there instead of
Garoppolo because you had Garoppolo as
insurance for Tom Brady and then all of
a sudden abruptly Garoppolo is in San
Francisco that would have been a tough
pill to swallow and I know everybody was
holding their breath probably thought it
would never come to that but that would
have been a difficult one because I
don't believe they would have won that
game without Brady is it fair to include
Brady in the conversation with Michael
Jordan of decorated athletes not not
better athlete but let's say he wins his
six though he's matched Mike with six
titles even though he what he played in
eight Superbowl
and Mike with six NBA Finals yeah yeah I
think he's definitely is in that
conversation and those guys are great
competitive now you know me and you know
I'm old school I don't I put both of
those guys and nots below Bill Russell
well Russell is the most decorated team
player of all time but but he everybody
wants they but but but I have to do it I
have to put a butt in there because you
know that's guy stayed together there
was no free agency you know they won you
could get to the finals sooner less
games n-c-double-a I know
hey why fix Olympic game yep undefeated
in do-or-die games 11 rings but but I
don't want to hear but okay but if we
take Bill Russell out of the equation
out now yep give me the give me the game
plan for the Eagles to win this game the
Eagles have to first of all figure out
defensively how they're gonna deal with
the inside receivers what I see is Dion
Lewis James White
Gronkowski Amendola in the middle of the
field and they're gonna have to pack it
in so tight that that's gonna give cooks
some real opportunities one-on-one and
this is why they got cooks for this
strategy if you're gonna take away all
that and commit so many people inside
I've got to be able to throw one on one
outside the only way the Eagles are
gonna disrupt that is with pass rush and
they know it they're our defensive line
talking to those guys it's on us
we as good as much as we like our guys
in the back
they can't handle all of those receivers
so we've got to get pressure the other
side of the the game plan is pretty
simple this is gonna be the run pass
options Nick Foles is gonna read it and
he's got to throw when that's available
and probably most of the time it is
gonna be throw because I'm sure New
England's gonna take away the run so
Foles has to be efficient not to turn
the ball over and the defensive line has
to press to the pass I think New
England's gonna throw 55 yeah I do too
it's good but I think it's gonna be no
huddle
I think Brady's gonna have tempo there
and not let them substitute and that's
okay they're fine not substituting if
they can get pressure explain to me what
this
means to you the Pat Summerall Ward that
you're gonna get Thursday night the
dinner benefiting st. Jude Children's
Research Hospital Pat Summerall was
legendary in this business just a guy
who was class and longevity and doing
things the right way and to ask to be
honored and over the course of your
career doing things the right way and
doing things for the community it's
gonna be be pretty awesome and to be
here in the town where I went to school
I coached as an assistant coach a lot of
my formative years were here it couldn't
have been better timing well well did
well deserved as well humming you know
but you know you're getting all these
awards and then we have to call you a
Hall of Famer we can't I can't say Tony
[Laughter]
there's always a title that goes with
you that's hard I mean it's you know I
have to catch myself because when I say
hey Tony and then you don't turn around
ago Hall of Famer where's the bus that
I'm going on you're right thanks great
hall-of-famer
he's NBC football night in America now
getting another award here Continental
Tire coaches corner with Tony Dungy for
more Dan Patrick show to the audience
Channel 239 on DirecTV or download the
Dan Patrick show app
[Music]